les chroniqueurs glisse elle-même époux
cave dans cette boîte guillaume genton
le podium gens ni si les mangues et aux
jeunes gens tombent d'accord adore les
filles qui font de la télé réalité
contrait à son tableau de chasse
plusieurs stars du
show ouais c'est moche ce dernier qui
savent pas du tout écrit ça alors déjà
delphine ne fait pas de télé réalité non
ensuite et je rappelle que guillaume
genton c'est un gentleman la pac tableau
de chasse au tueur avec twin exactement
bravo exactement non et j'ai eu une
histoire et quelques années avec
l'équipe
non non mais l'aurait on va pas avoir
des problèmes tous les soirs c'est bon
c'est bon esprit alors donc si vous avez
une malle à une très belle histoire est
l'histoire d'un mec de courtrai qu'un le
connaît oui oui vous me connaissez je
connais moins en version allemande oui
que j'aime bien je sais
c'est passé et oubliez pas que certains
tabous ici non et donc elle a fait la
téléralité oui bien longtemps et annoncé
en marine est la forêt la télé tout
court brune aussi en basse et ben voilà
c'est vous bon bah sinon story
c'est afida turner
obama
c'est magnifique non alors non j'aime
beaucoup donc je sais moi aussi j'ai
cassé la wii meglena que je connais tout
à midi aujourd'hui bref quoi vous croyez
vous êtes vous quoi il est avec moi
c'était
alors voilà ue bravo félicitations si
j'étais amoureux ont été longues et
ouais des tirs ont un peu os non six
mois commencé moi c'est les psy way est
resté six mois avec une star de télé
réalité c'est beau c'est beau si c'est
une star c'est une star c'est une vraie
c'est pas genre à la fait non c'est pas
le genre mathilde des songes 12
heures n'ont pas c'est vraiment c'est
quelqu'un de très très très connu c'est
une des plus connues annoncé l'une des
plus connues est bon on peut pas des
relations donne le prénom et la virile
veux pas dire mais c'est une des plus
connues
il a fait ça la fait salle était connu
pour ça mais je tiens à peine plus
madame r version
mais les excès comme si tu dis nagui tu
sais qui c'est tout de suite oui bah
voilà bah là c'est pareil non
ta mère
[Applaudissements]
mais qui a balancé sa cause et bref
c'est plus classe je sais pas mais je
pense que c'est qu'un stade alors j'ai
mais alors jamais choix sur personne
d'accord